so there's a bunch of reasons why a
website might want to track you and
depending on your opinion you might
think some of these are reasonable and
you might think some of them are
unreasonable
just to understand imagine if you were
to go to say khan academy and you were
to do some work well it might be nice
that if you were to come back another
day
that that work isn't lost and so that
might be a reason why you would want
khan academy to know who you are now
there's a bunch of different ways that
this could happen the most obvious way
is by having an account with a username
and a password so when you type in your
username and password the site knows
exactly who you are it can retrieve your
data from a database and then you can
pick up right where you left off that's
probably the most obvious to people and
it's also the most obvious how to not be
tracked in that way is that you log out
but just because you logged out or just
because you don't have a username and
password doesn't mean that you can't be
tracked by a site there's several other
ways that can be tracked that you should
know about and also know how to undo
them if possible
another way is leveraging something
called cookies
cookies even if you don't have an
account on a site most web browsers are
going to allow the website to place a
little bit of text on your computer so
the browser which is running on your
computer is going to place it so that
next time your browser goes to that site
again the site will say okay this is the
same person whose cookie i put there and
then there might that cookie might have
a little bit of data associated with it
and say okay there could be some useful
things we can pick up where we left off
we can customize for what you're looking
for or you might say that's a little bit
creepy that a site that i didn't give
permission to is able to keep track of
me and so you might want to delete your
cookies which your browser will allow
you to do
now cookies as i said they have their
benefits
these this is one of the reasons why you
can often stay logged in to a website
because the website says oh this is
cookie this is this is the person who
keeps logging in
it might you might want the
personalization of the advertisements or
any other customizations without logging
in and that's where cookie could be
useful but if you don't want it of
course you can delete it now another way
that a website can keep track is your ip
address when your web browser which is
running on your computer or on your
phone
wants to look at a website it sends a
request to that website and then that
request sends the data sends the website
back and so in order to send the data
back it needs an address for your phone
or for your computer and that's going to
be in the form of an ip address
now you can imagine if that site knows
your ip address and then if you were to
come from the same device with the same
ip address again it'll say okay it's at
least the same device maybe it's the
same person and then they might be able
to track you in that way once again it
might be for some good uses like
customization or maybe it's things that
you aren't so comfortable with
now what gets extra interesting and
might be useful or not useful depending
on your point of view is that it's not
necessarily just your relationship with
one website for example you might have
an advertiser that puts cookies on a
bunch of websites and so can keep track
of you as you go from site to site and
so then it's getting at least for me
i don't like the fact that people can
see
what how i'm moving around on the
internet or i remember recently i was
looking for
a mountain bike and i did it on one
e-commerce site and then all of a sudden
it seemed like the whole internet knew
that i wanted to buy a mountain bike i
didn't end up buying a mountain bike now
some of you might say that's nice you
know the internet knows i want a
mountain bike i'd like i'd like to keep
being presented with ads on mountain
bikes some of you might say hey that's
not so cool i was just well you know a
random search i did and it's kind of
weird that the internet is starting to
build this profile of me of someone who
might be in the market for mountain
bikes and so once again deleting your
cookies can go a long way to preventing
that type of thing if you're
uncomfortable with it
and then ip addresses that's a little
bit harder to hide sometimes you have
dynamic ip addresses sometimes it
changes but the the clearest way of
protecting your ip address is if you use
something like a virtual private network
which does get a little bit more a
little bit more complex now related to
all of this some of you also might be
thinking about being tracked when you do
a search you might see that hey these
suggested searches that the the site is
giving it seems like it's kind of
specific to me and that's because in
many cases it is the search engine
probably has placed cookies or it's
keeping track with an ip address of
things that you have searched for before
and the things that you have clicked on
and so it could use that maybe to give
you different search results maybe to
change what the autocomplete is
it also might be keeping track of a
search history
so the search history could be useful if
you want to look at other sites that you
have been to before or you might not
want that around you might not want the
wrap you might not want the the site or
someone else who if you just happen to
be using your computer to see what
you've been searching for so most
browsers sorry most search engines are
going to let you delete that
so
there's a lot more to it this is just
kind of the tip of the iceberg
but think about how you may or may not
be tracked and think about how you may
or may not want to be tracked and good
hygiene is especially if you're at a
public computer log out of things that's
also so other people can't use use your
account
really be thoughtful about whether you
even want to create an account for a
site is this something that you really
need what are going to be the benefits
for you think about whether you want to
accept cookies i would recommend
deleting cookies pretty regularly it
might have some negatives you might have
to re-log into a few sites but there's
probably a lot of other shady sites that
no longer
can track what you're doing but even if
you do all of those things still be very
careful and very conscientious